when we observe the physical world we
find random fluctuations everywhere
we can generate truly random numbers by
measuring random fluctuations known as
noise when we measure this noise known
as sampling we can obtain numbers for
example if we measure the electric
current of TV static over time we will
generate a truly random sequence
we can visualize this random sequence by
drawing a path that changes direction
according to each number known as a
random walk notice the lack of pattern
at all scales at each point in the
sequence the next move is always
unpredictable random processes are said
to be non-deterministic since they are
impossible to determine in advance
machines on the other hand are
deterministic their operation is
predictable and repeatable in 1946 John
von Neumann was involved in running
computations for the military
specifically involved in the design of
the hydrogen bomb using a computer
called the ENIAC he planned to
repeatedly calculate approximations of
the processes involved in nuclear
fission
however this required quick access to
randomly generated numbers that could be
repeated if needed
however the ENIAC had very limited
internal memory storing long random
sequences was not possible so Neumann
developed an algorithm to mechanically
simulate the scrambling aspect of
randomness as follows first select a
truly random number called the C's this
number can come from the measurement of
noise or the current time in
milliseconds next the seed is provided
as input to a simple calculation
multiply the seed by itself and then
output the middle of this result then
you use this output as the next seed and
repeat the process as many times as
needed this is known as the middle
squares method and is just the first in
a long line of pseudo-random number
generators the randomness of the
sequence is dependent on the randomness
of the initial seed only same seed same
sequence so what are the differences
between a randomly generated versus
pseudo randomly generated sequence
let's represent each sequence as a
random walk they seem similar until we
speed things up the pseudo-random
sequence must eventually repeat this
occurs when the algorithm reaches a seed
it has previously used and the cycle
repeats the length before a
pseudo-random sequence repeats is called
the period the period is strictly
limited by the length of the initial
seed for example if we use a two-digit
seed then an algorithm can produce at
most 100 numbers before reusing a seed
and repeating the cycle a three-digit
seed can expand past a thousand numbers
before repeating its cycle and a
four-digit seed can expand past 10,000
numbers before repeating though if we
use a seed large enough the sequence can
expand into trillions and trillions of
digits before repeating though the key
difference is important when you
generate numbers pseudo randomly there
are many sequences which cannot occur
for example if Alice generates a truly
random sequence of 20 shifts it's
equivalent to a uniform selection from
the stack of all possible sequences of
shifts this stack contains 26 to the
power 20 pages which is astronomical in
size if we stood at the bottom and shine
the light upwards a person at the top
would not see the light for around 200
million years
compare this to Alice generating a 20
digit
pseudo-random sequence using a four
digit random seed now this is equivalent
to a uniform selection from 10,000
possible initial seeds meaning she can
only generate 10,000 different sequences
which is a vanishingly small fraction of
all possible sequences when we move from
random to pseudo-random shifts we shrink
the key space into a much much
smaller seed space so for a
pseudo-random sequence to be
indistinguishable from a randomly
generated sequence
it must be impractical for a computer to
try all seeds and look for a match this
leads to an important distinction in
computer science between what is
possible versus what is possible in a
reasonable amount of time we use the
same logic when we buy a bike lock
we know that anybody can simply try all
possible combinations until they find a
match and it opens but it would take
them days to do so though for eight
hours we assume it's practically safe
with pseudo-random generators the
security increases as the length of the
seed increases if the most powerful
computer would take hundreds of years to
run through all seeds then we safely can
assume it's practically secure instead
of perfectly secure as computers get
faster the seed size must increase
accordingly pseudo randomness frees
Alice and Bob from having to share their
entire random shift sequence in advance
instead they share a relatively short
random seed and expand it into the same
random looking sequence when needed but
what happens if they can never meet to
share this random seed